The first
real issue and the question that I need
to pose to you is can you annunciate or
list the things which invalidate the
actions which invalidate the fast of
Ramadan.
>> Alhamdulillah.
especially
as far as acts which invalidate the fast
they listed in the Quran as well as in
the hadith ofam.
Allah says in the Quran
in surah bakar
chapter number two verse number 187
associate with them that's your wife and
take whatever Allah gives you from them
that is offspring and eat and drink
till the white thread of dawn
appears different than the black thread
and then you fast and complete your fast
till the nightfall.
So here we get the three categories
eating, drinking and sexual intercourse
and there are various other categories
which are prohibited in the say hadith.
Broadly if you list the things that
break the fast there are approximately
10 different things which break the fast
and you can categorize them into two
categories. The first category is that
which breaks the fast when we take it
inside the body. In them there are four
things. The first is eating and
drinking. Second is anything that falls
in the same category as eating or
drinking. Third is taking medicines or
pills or injections which are in the
form of nourishment or somewhat similar
to eating and drinking
including blood transfusion. The fourth
is
somewhat similar to kidney diialysis
where the blood is taken out, it's
purified and some nutrients are put into
it and put back. The second category
that which comes out from the body,
there are six things in them. Number one
is sexual intercourse. Number two is
masturbation.
Number three is menstruation. Number
four is post-natal bleeding.
Number five is
deliberate vomiting and number six is
letting out blood somewhat similar to
cupping or something similar to that. So
in all there are 10 things which
invalidate the fast.